if everyone you loved was suddenly
getting killed by horrifying aliens what
would you do they can shapeshift into
anyone you know and now nobody can be
trusted i'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the aliens in parasite this kid
has no idea that he's supposed to die
shinichi here goes to sleep after a hard
day and puts on his headphones when
suddenly this insane alien sneaks into
his room but shinichi wakes up in shock
to this terrifying creature as it tries
to burrow into his arm and make its way
to his reign thinking fast this kid ties
his arm up until it turns each red
because of his screams for help his
parents come running in to see what's
going on but just like that the hole in
his arm disappears as if it were a
horrifying dream the next day he goes
through his usual routine but realizes
that he feels different he's about to
cross the street when suddenly a car
honks its horn at him and he takes a few
steps back he then looks back at the
road and sees a little girl running into
traffic chasing after a ball in a matter
of seconds this tiny little girl is
about to have her blood paint the
sidewalk without realizing it shinichi's
body moves on its own and jumps out in
front of the car to protect the girl and
blocks it with his hand completely
destroying the car but he's totally fine
he looks at his hand in shock and sees a
horrifying eye staring right back at him
and then it disappears shinichi then
runs home desperate to find some answers
he takes out a knife and gets ready to
cut off his own hand in horror he sees
his hand transform into an alien and it
speaks okay i no longer have full
control over my own hand and now
something else is inside and controlling
it and right now i'm suddenly starting
to wonder am i hallucinating an alien
that's coming out of my hand because
this sounds something exactly like a
science fiction novel and i would rather
believe i'm infected with a specific
kind of virus that can cause visual
hallucinations instead of an actual
alien now living inside of my own hand
we live in japan and there just so
happens to be a virus in rural areas of
southeast asia and the far east known as
the japanese encephalitis virus and this
virus does in fact cause hallucinations
and while symptoms could appear this
virus can cause mild to no symptoms in
certain people in the very beginning
which could explain why i am now
starting to trip balls with seemingly no
reason whatsoever also every two in
three people who catch this virus on
average go on to develop more serious
symptoms and this could explain why i'm
suddenly feeling fine and now
hallucinating an alien living in my hand
in order to preserve my sanity i would
ride this hallucination train and see
what the hell this alien has to say
because in the best case my
hallucination is full of [ __ ] and i can
go to the hospital and endure several
months of painful recovery and worst
case my hallucination isn't a
hallucination and the doctors won't know
what to do and contact the government
and now have me shipped off to japan's
version of area 51. shinichi is
horrified as hell and this alien tells
him that it has taken over his arm
forever but then it suddenly goes to
sleep leaving shinichi more clueless and
terrified than before he spends the
whole night trying to find out anything
that he can on this alien when morning
comes he wakes up to see his hand
attached to a crazy creature reading
shinichi thinks he's in a nightmare but
this alien explains to him that the
horrors have only just begun it says it
doesn't know where it came from only
that it had to take over his brain but
apparently got stuck in his arm instead
and failed it warns this kid that if he
tries to tell anyone about this
situation the government will probably
capture him for horrifying experiments
did i not just say that dang i'm good
this alien mentions to shinichi that
since they're now stuck with each other
they should work together for now in the
morning shinichi's family hears on the
news about more horrifying murders that
have recently started popping up in
japan later while out on a walk
shinichi's alien friend senses another
alien creature nearby shinichi freaks
out but the alien tells him that finding
answers to what's going on will help
both of them they confront the alien and
find out that it's inside a dog's body
and that this creature is hungry
shiniji's alien tells him to get to
cover and the two prepare for shinichi's
first battle but to their surprise it
ends quickly with shiniji's alien
killing this one by taking out its heart
the kid's alien tells him that they won
this time because the hostile alien
wasn't able to merge properly with its
host giving shinichi a valuable edge in
combat and that this is something he
should remember for later okay while
this may seem insane that we have an
alien residing inside of our hand and
somehow our body is not rejecting it on
earth there is a little devil known as
the spyro metra tapeworm that can do the
same thing that this alien is doing
living inside the body of a human
without causing bodily complications the
spirometric tapeworm can live inside of
the brain of a human for up to 20 years
without causing any problems and this
actually happened to a dude in china in
a way shinichi should be grateful that
his body isn't rejecting it and this
alien isn't able to take over his body
or spread little larva inside of him
which by the way the tapeworm known as
the tinia solium can do this tiny little
honey bunches of oats can burrow itself
inside of the body and can cause
infection from the larva that this
parasite has imagine this little darling
bringing little larva babies into the
world at the expense of your body
causing organ damage in the lungs brain
liver and a bunch of other nasty crap at
the moment we know that the alien cannot
fully take over shinichi's body which
means we should put aside the thought of
trying to remove it and instead focus on
working with him because from what we
saw of how the two interacted during
that fight with the dog alien they got
lucky there are other ones out there
like them that aren't going to be so
easy they need to learn to work together
and fast shinichi realizes that he'll
die if he doesn't team up with this
alien and begins to call it migi and
then finds out that the gruesome murders
happening all over japan have started to
happen all over the world and this girl
says that the police here are trying to
keep things quiet but videos of these
murders have leaked onto the internet
according to migi the aliens feed on
whatever species they inhabit the alien
invades a dog and now eats dogs the
alien invades a human it eats humans
shinichi realizes that these murders
mean that the horrifying alien invasion
has already begun worldwide after school
shinichi takes a walk when suddenly migi
senses another alien headed straight for
them and this time this alien is a stone
cold killer migi demands that shinichi
gets the hell out of there but instead
this kid walks toward the killer mickey
calls shinichi a crazy bastard but this
kid is determined to stop this alien
invasion all by himself and that's when
they come face to face with this alien
and they prepare for battle but this
blonde baddie then reveals something
terrifying and says that migi can in
fact invade his body instead and that
all he has to do is to kill shinichi
before he goes this guy cuts off his arm
and leaves it wide open for miki he
demands that shinichi dies and raises
his tentacle to kill him when suddenly
miki blocks it and slices him to pieces
shocking blondie and shinichi both migi
tells shinichi that it simply didn't
trust this alien and decided not to join
him inside of that body and tell
shinichi to cool it on the bromasse the
next day shinichi celebrates his victory
by living his life ordinary and his
parents tell him that they're leaving
for a few days on a hubba hubba type of
a trip and shinichi leaves for school
but later migi pops up again with more
bad news and tells shinichi that it
senses another alien nearby shinichi's
hairs stand on end as him and satomi
head into class nearby in the hall migi
tells shinichi to stand guard as the
alien nearby is looking for them and
they realize that the alien close by is
in fact their new substitute math
teacher ryoko okay this is some serious
texas chicken [ __ ] but there's
something up with this scenario that
makes me think that we're not as doomed
as shinichi thinks he is now thanks to
migi we know that these things are
officially a race of aliens that have
floated down to earth from unknown
origins just like little dandelion seeds
floating in the wind and they act
similar to the parasite tapeworm teenia
solium and those things burrow
themselves inside of the body and try to
take over the central nervous system but
these aliens once they take over a human
host are instinctively driven to hunt
and kill humans and they seem to act
similar to a virus because this thing at
the end of the day seems to be nothing
more than a brainless non-living
freeloader who will kill us at any
chance it gets unless it seriously wants
something from us and here's where i
think we still hold all of the cards
this alien has infiltrated our school to
the point of being an employed teacher
being this deep undercover within the
human population is not the norm it
means that this alien has an agenda
otherwise why else would it go through
all of this trouble when it could just
attack everyone right here and now this
means that this alien is different it
wants something until he gets what it
wants it's not going to attack us
otherwise it would have done so already
for the time being as long as we're
surrounded by dozens of students and
faculty members this alien isn't going
to touch us even if it desperately wants
to and we should use this opportunity to
confront this thing right after the
assembly while we're still surrounded by
witnesses shinichi spends the day
sweating buckets wondering what this
horrifying alien ryoko is up to but
later runs into her at this cafe and is
offered a peace treaty she introduces
another alien friend to shinichi and
mentions that she wants to maintain her
cover because she is pregnant this chick
has begun horrifyingly steamy
experiments with this dude trying to
create half human half alien babies just
like shinichi and says that they both
should not get in each other's way but
this alien dude who looks dumb as bricks
says that the peace treaty is stupid and
he leaves and prepares to kill shinichi
very soon the next day in class shinichi
studies when suddenly both ryoko and
migi warn him that trouble is coming
it's the dumbest bricks dude and he's
coming to kill shinichi but this time
this kid prepares to stand his ground
and sets up a mini shitty fortress that
doesn't look all that impressive but
this cold-hearted killer is ruthless and
surprises him through the window but
migi quickly tells shinichi that these
aliens think humans are too scared to
fight them so they'd never expect
shinichi to try and kill them migi then
sets up a plan giving this kid a weapon
and tries to keep the alien distracted
as shinichi cautiously tries to go for
this monster's heart they work together
in harmony until shinichi manages to
stab this alien right in his soft spots
and blood spills everywhere and this
alien walks off to die later as the
school cleans up the mess shinichi
leaves the area and runs into ryoko
again she's pissed as hell she mentions
that the school fired her for just what
happened and blames it on shinichi she
prepares to skin him alive but he begs
her to listen to him for one second he
mentions that migi feeds off his blood
and tells her that aliens can survive
without killing humans because of this
but ryoko thinks that it's simply
natural selection killing off humans but
then she realizes something shinichi is
becoming more alien than human and
thinks migi will soon take over his
entire body she goes away and leaves
shinichi behind and he wonders if it's
only a matter of time until his human
side dies a few days later shinichi
enjoys life without his parents at home
when suddenly he gets a call from his
dad he says in broken words to shinichi
that his mother is dead and mentions
that a horrifying monster did it and the
call suddenly ends shinichi is frozen in
shock but migi shows up and tells him
something even more terrifying it says
that the monster alien who killed
shinichi will likely come for him next
and the two prepare for the horrors that
are about to show up at their doorstep
this is so not fair this should be party
time the parents are out of town and it
is now turned into a real debbie downer
here's what we know we know for certain
that the enemy parasite is going to need
at least half a day's ride to get to us
we know where our parents went the alien
coming for us is going to take a few
hours minimum to reach us this means we
have some time to prepare these alien
parasite things while hard to kill can
be killed as we saw with the dog
parasite thing these aliens rely on the
host's body's capabilities to an extent
just like dumb as bricks guy from before
puncturing their vital organs or
severing the head is enough to kill them
which makes them arguably similar to
humans which means we just need a clear
shot to kill it's noted that our daddy
said a monster killed our mama not
monsters plural which means we know for
a fact that we're up against one alien
bastard and this alien bastard simply
needs to have a knife plunged into his
soft spots or we can go a little extra
with our methods because we don't know
anything about this alien or its host so
i'd say let's up the antics and go on a
little more flammable measure if i was
shinichi i would go to the nearest gas
station and fill up some containers full
of gasoline next i would do the google
and buy the biggest water gun that the
store has preferably a super soaker of
some sort and fill it with gasoline from
there i would buy some thin glass
bottles motor oil and some leather
gloves and use the fabric shirts in my
house to make some molotov cocktails
next went back home if i was shinichi i
would turn on the gas stove and begin
heating up a bunch of knives from the
kitchen for however long we've got left
the parasite is all about
self-preservation and keeping itself
alive which means its system will react
to any sort of heat being placed on its
skin in a negative way causing it to
overreact and make mistakes this alien
will freak out at the induction of a
heated weapon plus having its entire
body set on fire it will be too
preoccupied to focus on us we'll get a
warning from migi once it's near while
migi keeps it busy we will soak the
bastard in gasoline at a distance first
with our water gun then we'll use our
molotov cocktails to set this guy on
fire once we find an opening we'll stab
this thing in the heart with our red hot
knife migi is highly intelligent and
will easily be able to help us out in
setting this up and coordinating the
plans to take this alien bastard down
shinichi needs to get off of his ass and
start preparing the next day arrives
more sinister than before shinichi wakes
up to migi telling him that the alien
killer is right outside he's shocked and
grabs a knife to prepare for combat
waiting in the shadows until he comes
face to face with the killer it's his
mom realizing that the alien has taken
over his mother shinichi panics and
stops migi from attacking just as he
gets stabbed through the heart
collapsing on the floor and sees the
cold face of his mother reacting with no
emotion she leaves the two to die right
there as migi thinks fast and it does
something insane it merges with
shinichi's heart forcing this little
wuss's heart to keep beating shiniji
miraculously begins healing as migi
slowly brings him back from the dead
days pass when shinichi finally wakes up
and feels almost better than human he
suddenly gets a call from a far away
hospital where his dad is resting and
prepares to go to see him as soon as
possible he opens the door and waves
goodbye to satomi and this kid prepares
to go to fight his demons in the flesh
meanwhile shinichi's dad at the hospital
is horrified to learn that his wife is
not dead and has been spotted around
town the dad said he saw shinichi's
mother get brutally murdered right in
front of him but the doctors think he's
simply gone insane shinichi finally
arrives and the dad all pumped up on
meds tells him to chill out because
everything is fine but shinichi knows
everything is not fine and shit's about
to hit the fan he decides to stay in
town for a few days to watch over his
dad but that night amigi reveals
something horrifying it tells shinichi
that because amigi merged his entire
body within shinichi's this
transformation has come at a terrifying
cost migi has begun to pass out every
day for four hours and will now not be
able to sense any bad guys that try and
attack shinichi or his dad during this
time okay this could be a serious
problem shinichi's physiology has been
altered at the cost amigi the extreme
amount of effort needed from migi to
save him now forces migi to need a
literal power nap every day this sucks
now i gotta worry about what i'm gonna
do when migie goes to sleep what we have
to figure out as soon as possible is is
that does it matter when miki goes to
sleep or does he really only need a nap
whenever he gets completely tapped out
energy wise how much does it take out of
him to augment shinichi's body whenever
he bites other aliens how quickly can we
get migi tired these are the things that
we need to know we gotta figure out how
to get as much done as possible when
migi is awake because now we have to
come up with alternatives on how we
protect our daddy if mig's nap time is
dependent on its energy usage then i'm
gonna try to use him as little as
possible and find a spot where we can
hide up in for a while whenever migi
needs his nap we don't know when that
alien scum is gonna attack our father
this means until we get a workaround on
this thing we'll effectively be on edge
24 7. and
it sucks now the most obvious period of
time to strike our dad would be during
the hours of the night when the hospital
will be the most empty however knowing
the alien entering the hospital during
the hours of the day will be the best
time to strike as this will allow it to
enter and blend in through bigger crowds
without a rising too much suspicion and
picking the least obvious option to
attack during the day will be likely
when it chooses to strike as this thing
is one sneaky mother of a pearl
therefore we gotta figure out miki's nap
times right now migi is my ace in the
hole and i need to be able to use him
whenever a crisis arises the next day
migi suddenly senses an enemy at the
beach nearby shinichi rushes like health
and prepares to take out his dad's
attacker but all he finds is this guy
the least alien hybrid ever and they
realize that this guy is just like
shinichi a parasite human hybrid with a
big mouth and i mean that literally big
mouth here works near the hospital that
shinichi's dad is in and he happily
offers to warn shinichi if any enemies
show up near his pops while migi is
sleeping
this guy is one lonely dude later migi
points out something interesting and
mentions that earlier on the way to the
beach shinichi ran and jumped like
someone with superpowers but amigi tells
him something even more insane migi
declares that its cells are now no
longer just within shinichi's hand after
restarting shinichi's wussy heart migi
cells have now spread all throughout
this kid's body making shinichi stronger
faster and less human just then he gets
a call from big mouth and he tells
shinichi that him and his alien friend
have spotted a horrifying parasite but
shinichi knows that these creatures are
smarter than anyone thinks and he tells
big mouth to get out of there before he
gets his clumsy ass spotted but it's
already too late shinichi runs as fast
as possible to find big mouth but amigi
suddenly gives shinichi a sword before
it passes out again leaving him all
alone for the most terrifying fight of
his life he suddenly hears big mouths
screams nearby falling over this cliff
shinichi shows up only to find his worst
enemy instead his mother or what's left
of her a mindless alien ready to kill
pissed off shinichi slices and dices
this alien bastard but at the last
minute he chokes looking at his mother's
loving eyes
it's so nice right this alien bastard
then takes advantage of shinichi's
weakness and prepares to kill him right
then but all of a sudden an injured big
mouth comes back from the cliff and
brutally kills shinichi's mother's alien
corpse once and for all big mouth then
mentions that aliens think little of
humans and they repeat their fight
patterns since they think most humans
won't test their skills this is their
weakness the gang saves the day and his
dad is all better shinichi takes his
family back to his hometown but this is
only the beginning of his horrifying
transformation shinichi realizes that
he's now become even stronger and faster
than before as if he's evolving but
something's not right shiniji asks migi
for advice he's starting to feel less
human and hasn't been able to feel any
emotions since he came back from the
dead but miki thinks that he's just
becoming a more efficient human okay
this is some serious baskin robbins 31
flavors type of bull crap shinija here
has started to feel weird and i wouldn't
put it past him to think that what's
happening to him is a direct result of
migi's diddling with his body on a
cellular level but here's something
crazy to think about what shinichi is
experiencing in terms of feeling like
his personality has changed could
actually be rooted in real life science
we don't know the exact methods through
which migi saved shinichi's life but we
do know what he effectively did was an
organ transplant to some degree miki
basically transferred some of its
cellular dna into shinichi's body
healing shinichi using cells from its
own alien body but here's where it
actually gets kind of crazy because
shinichi could be feeling like his body
is changing due to a concept in science
called body memory body memory is the
medical hypothesis not yet fully proven
that suggests that not just the brain
but the body itself is capable of strong
memories on a cellular level think about
how crazy that sounds for a second think
about it because the rundown of this
whole thing is that personality changes
following organ transplants have been
reported by patients for nearly decades
worldwide and these reports have varied
from people claiming that they've had
changes in emotions changes in identity
and inheriting memories from their
donor's life now i know this sounds
crazy and while this isn't considered
100 scientifically validated or properly
understood through any type of
scientific lens as of yet this could be
one theory to help explain how and why
shinichi is experiencing changes in his
state of being and let's not forget
migi's genetic code is clearly something
that has not come from this planet okay
we don't know yet if what mighty has
done to shinichi is going to end out
well long term the next day at school
migi senses another alien monster headed
right for them but this one is different
and catches up to them during gym class
he introduces himself as shimada and
mentions that he only wants shinichi's
help this alien race has begun to look
for ways to coexist with humans without
eating them or so he says migi doesn't
trust this guy one bit and pulls
shinichi away mentioning they'll think
about this guy's offer later the police
send guys to check in on shinichi's dad
they tell him the truth that more and
more deaths have started happening
around japan and the government knows
that horrifying aliens are a real threat
the dad tells them what his alien
attacker looks like and the government
prepares themselves for a threat never
seen before the dad feels shinichi in
about what really happened to his mother
as shinichi silently listens keeping his
alien secret close to his chest but
glasses girl begins to suspect this
shimada kid over the next few days and
her gut tells her that something is not
right about this guy one day she notices
this dude get hit in the face with a
baseball and he horrifyingly fixes his
skull in front of her eyes shocked she
follows shimada into town and sees him
transform into another human this girl's
mind cracks and she prepares an acid
trap the following day at school but
shimada senses her plan and transforms
into a horrifying flesh-eating alien
right in front of her eyes and prepares
to eat her right then and there but this
chick throws the acid right in his face
distracting him while she escapes
through this window outside the football
team sees glass's girl fall and she
tells them what's really going on
shocked these kids run inside the school
to find this alien but unfortunately for
them they all get brutally sliced apart
horrifying everybody nearby people start
freaking out and this alerts shinichi
nearby he then decides to play hiro and
goes to kill shimada before he murders
anyone else the police reached the
school but they are no match for
shimada's horrifying powers migi then
offers a smart plan to sinichi and he
runs up into the building next door and
he waits for an exhausted shimada to
walk out just as this alien freak busts
open the rooftop door and shinichi puts
one stone cold hole right in his chest
killing him dead okay this is some
little house on the prairie type bull
crap due to his parasite's core physical
preservation mode his cells as a result
of whatever glasses girl did to him
means that shimada's body had begun to
freak out trying to protect him from
internal damage this freak out of his
cells means that she might have lost
control over his parasites cells and
this was likely the only reason that
shinichi was able to kill him as his
senses and body's motor control were a
little distracted this is also why
shimada walks out onto the rooftop still
in alien mode again this shows whatever
glasses girl did to him truly made him
lose control of his alien cells as he
was unable to disguise himself to turn
back into a human or well look like one
now while what shinichi did was smart in
the short term realistically japan's
finest would have probably been able to
trace that rock thrown back to the
direction of the building that shinichi
was standing on when he threw it and
most likely could have caught him while
going up that building through any
nearby cctv footage and or caught him
directly in the act of turning his arm
into an alien arm
this move was way too risky and could
have exposed his secret he should have
opted to blend in within the crowd
instead it's noted that at the battle
with blonde dude from earlier we won
that battle as that alien didn't expect
us a human to fight back and actually
attack it this is one of the other
weaknesses that these aliens face they
suffer from delusions of grandeur they
suffer from the fact that they think
they are more powerful than they really
are and because of this no human will
dare attack them and that is what we can
use against them going under the radar
and using these aliens confidence
against them would have been the smarter
move shinichi should have opted to
confront the alien nearby within the
school itself megi was able to detect
his location and could have retraced the
bloodshed leading into the initial room
that glasses girl was in and from there
we could have seen exactly what caused
shimada to freak out all of a sudden
within that room because all the screams
and killing came from the top floor of
the school which means shimada was calm
and in human form leading up to that
room and that means something caused him
to lose his
instantaneously going to the top floor
room and seeing the acid bottle that
glasses girl left and or driplets of it
dripping on the floor means that
shinichi could have known that from that
shimada was badly injured migi would
have known this because miggy's body and
shimada's alien body have the same
physiology and we could have used this
knowledge to confront shimata as he
tried to make his way to the roof and
killed him right there using some sort
of sharp object that we find along the
way while the key component of this plan
is simple killing shimada at close range
with an improvised edged weapon it still
would have allowed us to use the excuse
that we ran into him and killed out a
result of self-defense at least this is
what we could have told the police this
would not have given away our alien
secret to the police once they got their
forensic team to examine shimada's body
and we could have turned all the
attention that would have been on us
into simply a kid who got lucky and
lived we ran into this alien by accident
and we got lucky by killing it in order
to save our lives this would have been
the better move to cover our tracks into
killing shimada and would have been the
best move in order to keep our alien
secret safe the government is horrified
and tries their best to keep shimada's
alien bs a secret the next day they
discuss the ongoing alien invasion and
what terrors they must plan for but this
doctor has a genius idea he tells these
guys that the public should know about
these creatures and he's found a clever
way to tell humans and aliens apart if
you pull out a strand of parasite's hair
eyebrow eyelashes that single strand of
hair will melt within a few seconds
unlike a piece of hair from a human this
is how they'll be able to tell who is an
alien and who is a human but these
politicians don't realize that these
horrifying flesh-eating monsters have a
terrifying plan of their own meanwhile
shinichi is walking in town when he
stops dead in his tracks and looks
within this crowd he and miki realized
that these six people running for
government office are all parasites and
migi tells shinichi that the end of the
world is about to begin these parasites
have begun to take over the government
of japan and it won't be long before
they take over this country and
eventually the world and if you don't
want to be taken over by wrigley aliens
don't forget to like comment subscribe
and check out the how to be playlist
down below and check out next week's
video we're gonna do something crazy
something different it's gonna be hella
fun peace